thank you everybody i hope you're
enjoying the session this one's a more
serious session
okay yeah i was just running off with
the mouth as usual
talking i mean always i mean you know
that by now so
um my proposal is that we
focus on black today
and we just really cement things and
then next time we'll transition to white
because we have we have some time does
that sound good
works for me okay because the sicilian
is a pretty serious opening i really
want to make sure that
we're covering everything okay
[Music]
so um we'll we'll reconstruct what it is
exactly that people do against you now
i'm seeing this 52 games
knight f3 and uh the second most common
move is bishop c4 where you've responded
correctly to um every time
yeah so i'm just looking to see if
there's anything dangerous that was
played against you
okay so knight f3 now knight c6
okay so 27 games uh d4
11 games bishop c4 let's quickly review
bishop c4
good now most people have gone d3
against you
uh the rule of thumb i don't i know in
this position i don't bring up the g
pawn next right exactly nicely done you
don't bring up e6 and g6 at the same
time so here
it's a slightly different strategy okay
so so um bishop g5
has been played three times again so you
won all three games
okay uh chase it away first right oh you
can
you don't you don't necessarily have to
but uh you can go ahead and control the
center now
okay so i'd still just want to play this
anyway yep
and how are you gonna deal with this pin
uh if he takes the pawn i take the
bishop
if not then i just let's say bishop b3
um i just bring up the
the f7 right f7 bishop breaking yeah
bishop b7 exactly there should be seven
then you castle then you can
actually this bishop so this would be a
great example of
not actually getting this bishop to g4
although you can if he goes knight c3
you notice that he's putting pressure
pretty serious pressure on this pawn
so where would you put this bishop to
remedy that
just over to e6 and then
let's say that both sides castle and
let's say that white plays a move like
rookie one so one really good plan here
in this position
is to try to get b5 and how can you
prepare that move
by dropping that bishop back no
so remember that the best way to prepare
a pawn move is usually with another pawn
move
let's just go a6 first a6 and does the
purpose of b5 make sense yeah we're
trying to chase
the knight right well and we're also
trying to trap the bishop
so let's just make some random moves
you're actually trying to trap the
bishop another narrative super shooter
here
and uh d64 the bishop is trapped
but uh okay so i imagine though most
people when they see this then i didn't
notice it but i i would guess they'll
just push that a pawn next
yeah you mean they'll they'll play a3
yeah but uh
that's that's i think what most people
will do but the thing is um
after you play c4 anyway although you
don't
trap their bishop you can see that this
bishop is completely buried
yeah it's it's literally and it's
staring at the pawn chain
if it goes to b1 it's going to be
staring at them so bla white is
virtually playing without a piece
you can play queen c7 then rook d8 and
this is again a concept that
you know a couple of months ago i
wouldn't have bothered bringing up but
now i think you can wrap your head
around it
so like when you can
make your opponent's pieces this passive
uh for a prolonged period of time
that's a pretty big deal because they're
basically playing without that piece
that makes sense and uh yeah so there's
a good
example of this in in classical chess
but
we'll talk about that later so that's uh
that's perfect
now let's transition to to the main move
d4
go ahead okay so d4
c takes d4 knight takes d4 27 games
yep and now 16 people played knight
takes c6 that's the most common move
that's played against you
yeah and um right knight c6
now bc is correct now eight people go
knight c3
and uh that's the most common move
it's still just cheating right just
being carrying the bishop now three
games bishop d2 three games bishop c4
okay bishop c4 is the more i see what
you're saying i think so bishop c4 is
the more
uh active move so i can't bring my
knight up to where i want it because he
just pushes that pawn and i can't
take that pawn so i'd have right so this
is exactly the situation which you want
to avoid
yeah now if you accidentally played into
this situation
something that we talked about earlier
uh you actually have a very cool idea
here
that can help you get out of this you
can play knight g4
and this is only possible because
there's a bishop on c4 now queen takes
g4
what's the point
all i can see is pushing that d pawn to
attack the queen good
and attack what else the pawn
um think again you can win the piece
back
oh i see i put okay if he on poissants i
win the queen okay
pushing up to d5 good and then you win
the bishop back
so that's a crazy idea but what i wanted
to say is
even if you're you've allowed this and
you don't have niger for you can always
bring the knight back to ga
and it's not easy to just checkmate
black the knight can then redeploy
itself through h6 and f5
okay so my point is you're going to [ __ ]
up once in a while
in these positions and sometimes just
bringing the piece back
is better than you know panicking and
giving it up for example
so where do i want to go then from here
so you have two options here one the
best move is to play queen c7
and the purpose of this move is to cover
the e5 square
with the queen they're probably going to
castle and here
you go knight f6 and e5 is no not
possible because of queen takes c5
now if they try to prepare e5 with the
move f4
can you prevent e5 once again with your
pawns this time
yeah i can just bring up the d pawn
exactly
and now e5 isn't even that dangerous
because the knight is the g4 square
now you're gonna castle remember that
when they take on on c6 they open up the
b
file for you so you can always play the
move rook to b8 and then you can slowly
prepare
the pawn break d5
that makes sense so yeah you actually
the funny thing is against
uh you actually did play knight f6 here
three times and nobody played e5
but um now you're going to make sure
that you play queen c7
and yeah bishop so against bishop d2
which is a very awkward move i mean
knight f6 here actually is okay because
after e5
what additional square does the knight
now have no this is d5
yeah but still i wouldn't really bother
with this move now
uh the one of the reasons bishop d2 is
bad is because
the queen blocks the connection to d5 so
you can just play the move d5
and after it takes takes if they give
you a check on b5 how can you block this
check
with the bishop does that give up the d5
pawn
oh yeah because now it's not defended by
the queen are you sure about that
i think look at the whole board look at
what pieces are left undefended
oh then i just went as bishop you just
went especially and if he takes your
bishop after bishop d7
i take with the queen defending exactly
very nice so
that um that's basically the lay of the
land against these moves
the last thing that was played against
you more than once is bishop to d3
and uh here once again you have a choice
and both times you played the movie five
now you know that that's a bit of a
mistake
um so here you can play the move d6 and
then knight f6
or you could play queen queen up to c7
that's also fine
right so the key is to prevent e5 first
and then develop the knight
so would you prefer me stopping that
with the queen or with the d-pawn
usually i'll i'll put it this way i'll
make it easier and say with the d-pawn
there is a specific reason that after
bishop to c4
queen c7 is is marginally more accurate
but you know what you can play d6 here
anyway
this is fine this is fine and then
knight f6 and castles
so just stop it with the d-pawn and if
they try to enforce it somehow then
remember that you always have this in
your pocket
makes sense great uh so
now let's briefly review the moves that
are not knight takes c6
um six games knight c3 actually nine
games because
you transpose continue
and now once again a couple of people
took on c6 and three games continued
bishop e3
and and three times you played this
movie five which we now talk through
is it wrong uh in this position i still
want to just develop this
because you can't push that pawn right
now right
so the one person that you played this
against
this was the game that we actually um
played together
was f4 and if they play f4 to prepare e5
you do what
d pawn very nice now the only time that
you have to allow e5 they can play
knight takes c6
b takes c6 and they can play the movie
5.
and this is the one line that you have
to like memorize because
i'm pretty sure that this is going to
happen
against people who are slightly more
advanced at this stuff now here
you actually drop your knight back this
is theory you actually dropped your
knight back to g8
and uh black is actually in very good
shape here
trust me um i know it looks horrible at
first
but you see that this spawn is hanging
most people are going to defend the pawn
by playing f4 but now this knight can go
where
you can go h6 exactly and from h6 where
can it go
f5 potentially you can you can chill on
h6 now how are you going to break into
this pawn chain
to make sure that this bishop is once
again active
um is it just pushing the d pod again
you're a natural
okay but first i would castle so let's
say they developed their bishop i would
first castle to make sure the king is
safe
then after castles you can either bring
your knight into the game immediately
but
there's no hurry the knight is fine on
h6 i would play d6 here
and when he takes i take with pawn right
yeah take with the pawn and then
notice that the e file is also open so
you can bring the rook to
okay that sounds good no i mean
i can just sense that you you have good
understanding in these positions there's
a lot more to talk about but
that's basically everything that's been
played against you in the accelerated
um ludwig played bishop b5 and you
beat him and okay so what i'm noticing
really the only thing i'm noticing
you do consistently wrong is this move
e5 so against ludwig
what happened was he played here which
is a bit of an
empty move
so it was this this this now you castled
he castled
and uh guess what move you played
yeah you played e5 oh i pushed the pawn
yeah but what should you do here and
this is a bit tougher because you can't
really play d6
so what do you think you should do here
with black
is it just chase the bishop away exactly
go ahead now if the bishop moves back
then i'm still just wanting to push it
right and here's the thing
now that you've played the move b5 your
bishop on c8 can can go where
i can go to b7 and that's the double
fiance the bishop exerts pressure on the
pawn that's an ideal scenario
uh if the bishop moves backward then you
can play b5 but you can also now play d6
and get the bishop out this way
so very simple emphasis on development
for
preventing e5 and you almost never play
e5 yourself or even e6
yeah i just need to remember that i
think and and practice you know you're
doing everything right you just need a
lot of practice games what we're gonna
do also
next time is we're gonna delve a little
bit deeper into some of these games
um and talk about some middle game ideas
but for now i want you to really master
the opening moves which
you're in the process of doing let's
talk a little bit about d4
um because you mentioned that you were
struggling a little bit against this
move
uh i don't know what my stats are on it
but in almost every well pretty much
every game over the last two days i play
what levy taught which was going pretty
much the exact same brazilian on this
side
okay and that's called the dutch yeah
the dutch your stats are actually quite
good here so let's just uh review i
definitely like that choice it's a very
uh
it's an opening that's similar in in
spirit to what you're playing with the
accelerated dragon so
although it's it's a bit of a less cool
name yeah i think the accelerated dragon
just sounds so nice
but the dutch is a bit of a dubious
reputation but
wrongly so it's actually very solid
opening
okay so two people play bishop f4
against you i just want to test you on
the main
main ideas here okay um
newcastle e3
so in a lot of games i know i played
this and then pushed the e plug
and that's the ultimate idea that's
that's the correct plan okay
now can you push the e pawn here
like is it a good idea i mean you
obviously you can but
will you get your nuts dropped off if
you do that
wow well uh
just so because of that bishop move what
does that threaten with the plan
actually i was looking
at the c pawn here but
i don't think that's right well don't
over
i mean first kick i mean what what
should i do here
he just takes with pawn first takes us
with pawn and then takes with the knight
oh i so the ultimate idea is to go e5
but this needs to be prepared
so how do you prepare it i can bring my
knight over to g4
um ideally you'd want to prepare by
developing pieces though
oh i just bring my knight to c6 then
very good
and one of the cool things about the
dutch is that if
white plays d5 to attack your knight you
have a very very strong response you can
actually play e5 i don't know if lobby
showed you this idea
but this is an important idea in the
dutch
now how why does this move work first of
all what happens if he just takes your
knight
bishop you take his bishop that's a very
important bishop this is a
very beneficial trait for black and then
you can take his pawn
uh if the bishop moves then you just
move the knight and you've succeeded in
playing e5 if he takes on passant then
i just take the the pawn you just take
on e6 and you've got a great position
then you can play h6 g5 uh so does that
make sense
make sense now let's say that that white
castles
here um you have to be accurate
feel black to play right now yeah and i
think i've seen you play this correct
move before and i'm pretty sure levy
talked about this idea
it's a night it's a night move is it
going to e4
yeah and there's a couple of ideas so
first of all you open up the diagonal
for the bishop so now e5 actually
has been prepared but this trade on e4
it may look weird that you're
you're doubling the pawns but the
reality is there's a tactic here
that makes everything work out for black
so let's say the knight moves back to d2
find this tactic for black
[Music]
and it's an overloading tactic
so i'm just looking to reinforce that
pawn
um believe it or not you don't give a
damn about this plan
okay so that's worthless to the other
you see that the rook is
rook is kind of staring at the bishop
yeah what's defending that bishop
just upon just upon and that's a very
sort of
fragile situation right that pawn on e3
pawns are very often overloaded because
it's not only defending the bishop oh so
do i just take that d-pawn with the
win the bishop exactly you take the you
take the pawn of the knight and if he
takes back then you play rook takes that
f4 and you defend this pawn by the way
okay but of course white doesn't have to
take the knight white can take your pawn
right and you can take his bishop he
takes your knight now
nobody has won anything but you have
made a very big game
because you've eliminated an important
bishop you've opened up your bishop
and you basically have the two bishop
advantage now how about this bishop
where can it go where should it develop
itself to
uh i'm looking at f5 i see actually a
more
sexy option for the bishop don't forget
about the double fianchetto
uh because so i just want to do i want
to do the same idea a6
then b5 why a6 b5 why can't you just
ghetto it straight away so just push it
up one and then go in
exactly and why do i notice the idea of
the fan kiddo because
white is missing his light squared
bishop you just took it
so if white had a light-skirted bishop
he could have just put it on f3
but when your opponent doesn't have a
bishop of one particular caller and you
do
consider fianchettoing that bishop
because it's going to be super strong in
that long diagonal and it's going to be
uncontested
does that make sense makes sense so in
terms of attacking the king this is a
very good idea
so knight e4 is an idea you're basically
preparing e5
and not everybody's going to get their
bishop to force some of your opponents
played e3 which is a very bad move
it just keeps the bishop behind the pawn
chain now you just castle you play d6
um you know knight c6 and then you play
e5
and i think this is a good opening have
you felt okay in the dutch
yeah i think so for the most part it's
just a
i think a lot of times i don't know
where to go
like i pretty much no matter what they
play play the exact same five moves
without fail
yeah that's basically that that's
basically the case
okay is that like the right way of doing
that or should i be looking for other
things instead of just staying so
like textbook with it well there's
there's um
you know you are going to end up making
these moves but it's good practice to
at least pay attention to what your
opponent is doing
and uh you know your opponent could do
something crazy like he could play e4
in this position which would allow you
to do y
i just take you just take the pawn right
so
you want to look dynamically at what
your opponent is doing because some of
your opponents are going to do some
crazy stuff
just because of the nature of playing an
opening like this at your level like
people don't know it
uh but what i really want to emphasize
here no matter what white does um
your main plan is going to be to play e5
but um in if for whatever reason you're
having a hard time preparing e5
try to make natural moves try to develop
your pieces
uh you know don't shoot yourself in the
foot because white has ways of trying to
discourage you from playing e5
so that's gonna come with practice i'm
definitely going to pay attention to
your dutch games
but by and large yes you play the same
five moves against everything as long as
you just
pay more attention to what they're doing
okay so then uh
for this here uh let's bring knight to
c6 he pushes pawn up where do i want
that knight to go next
right so let's say castle's knight c6
now you want this knight to go to e5
okay so he takes that spot so knight
takes that spot and if knight takes you
take with a pawn
now at first sight it may seem like what
are we doing right the pawns are doubled
but in addition our bishop is now biting
on the pawn
but this pawn on him four on e5 what can
happen to it
what can you do with that pawn i can
just push it up right now you can push
it up
and what's going to happen is not only
does our bishop open but his bishop is
closed
and you've got a beautiful pawn chain
here so you've got a great position now
this pawn on d5 you can
you can undermine that pawn you can get
rid of it with what move
my double pawn right there push it to e6
right and that's why double pawns can be
so good right the other pawn
both pawns can have a very important
responsibility so you play e6
you've got a good free position and you
know then you can bring a rook to d it
really depends on what white does at
that point
okay that makes sense so no i mean as a
as a kind of introductory you you know
all the introductory ideas
it's just going to be all about getting
practice and
and i'm going to be paying attention to
your games as well and and with white
you and levy did talk about the vienna
gambit right
yeah so that's that's one that every
time i run it pretty much the same thing
happens they always take and i push
and i guess i don't know where i should
go there to make the most of the
position
okay let's let's maybe review that
quickly okay
uh because and then next time we'll
we'll really emphasize that now let me
just see
your white games what people actually do
so e4
e5 go ahead
okay so they usually go here right i'd
say
at least 50 percent go there so then i
play the the gambit here they
always take and i push right so they
basically have to get their knight back
to g8
yeah okay so
usually i play this to attack that pawn
and reinforce that one but i don't know
if that's
right so believe it or not that's a
mistake and
the reason that that's a mistake and
nobody actually exploited this against
you
but black has a very nasty move queen h4
check somebody did play this yeah
okay so somebody did play it yeah and um
you can see why this is annoying because
normally you would have the move g3
normally but here you don't have it
because of ftxg3
so you have to move your king out and so
what developing move can you make to
stop queen h4
i just played knight next to f3 you play
knight f3 and you actually did
play this i think once and your opponent
played the move
so you actually play this correctly one
second let me actually check my
let me check my notes so knight f3
d6 i didn't analyze this
so knight f3 your opponent played d6 and
now you continue to develop your pieces
which i really
like how uh
i bring in the bishop right i bring it
to c4 you bring the bishop to c4
um but actually sorry give me a second
i'm
checking my own analysis here
hmm yeah in my
notes d4 is a better move but i actually
like bishop c4
bishop c4 is good and after d takes e5
uh that pawn's hanging so just take that
pawn go ahead
now your opponents in this position
played the move bishop to d6
so real quick though if i do take this
can't he's delivered that same check
forcing me to move my king again
that's what i was analyzing so he can
but
uh that check is not nearly as dangerous
as it would be
earlier because now you have this f1
square for the king
okay this is not the greatest square in
the world but look at how many pieces
you've developed and how many pieces
he's developed
okay so this is a very very black can
survive here if he's super precise
but nobody's going to know and you can
trust me on this exactly how to play in
this position
and a case in point is that your
opponent played bishop to d6
which allows one move
oh that just from here
yeah white to play yeah it just gives me
this you just take and after queen h4
i move here and then i take the brook
you take the rope now you got to be a
little bit careful let's say they go
bishop to g4
here you have to continue being precise
because they're attacking your queen
yeah i can't drop my bishop because then
i hang my knight exactly that's a good
point
okay um do i just look to trade queens
here since i'm
exactly because you're going to win the
rook afterwards
so you play queenie one check nicely
done takes takes and then you and then
you take the rook
okay cool so in queen h4 you play
king f1 and just maybe one or two more
moves here so
the good players will give you that
check and then most people
who recognize the threat of knight takes
f7 i think that they're going to play
the move bishop to e6
to try to get your bishop off of that
square but now you take on e6
and you have another very active move
you see that this pawn is undefended how
can you attack it
um i can just develop the queen right
very good and uh black's only way of
developing of defending that font is to
play c6
but now you can simply play d3 and take
the pawn with the bishop and bring the
rook and you've got
pretty much an overwhelming position
okay cool oh that makes sense
and yeah that's that's the but the key
point is to play knight f3 here
rather than instead of pushing that d
pawn right away and eventually you can
play d4 and you can recover the pawn but
the emphasis is not on recovering the
pawn
so we'll work on this uh you know more
next time because i don't want to
overwhelm you with too many openings i
know it's
very tedious um so what do you say
we jump in maybe for one or two more
games to round it off
that sounds good to me
nice all right let's run it let's do it
let's see if we get right into oh right
into a vr all right
okay so that's just blunders upon yeah
baby
nice
all right now be careful about what you
want to take with yeah so i usually take
with the b
pawn but i see i'd hang that pawn so
exactly
nice thinking on your feet uh
just chase this away i think right sure
okay are you still protecting the pawn
right now if you want to protect that
pawn to the point where you don't have
to worry about it
push this
good
now this is a good example of where you
can actually castle to the
to the other side and you can
basically start attacking his king but
to attack his king you need to open a
file
to open a file you need to use your
pawns so do i just want to immediately
start doing that so g4
yeah exactly and you're going to open up
the g file what's going to
occupy that g file it's going to be the
h knight
you mean the rock sorry all right but
first be careful
yeah so positions here i i don't really
want to tuck my queen on g3 since i want
my rook there right so do i just want to
i just want to drop it like all the way
back to what like e3 is good
because that blockades the pawn it's you
use the pawn kind of as an umbrella
right you so he can't chase the queen
away with rookie eight
and in addition you can see that the
queen is making contact with the g5
square so if you go like rook g1 and
then g5
you'll be able to take that pawn with
the queen in the future
and then you'll have a battery on the g
file
so
all right you can go ahead and execute
that plan
very good so it makes sense why we're
putting a rokanji one
first yeah you're trying to when you
play g5 you want that move to be as
strong as possible
that's not threatening anything right he
still has two moves to make that work so
i still want to just push this right
right and it's good i'm glad that you
kind of asked yourself that
and he really can't make anything work
even if he attacks that b2 pawn with his
queen
even if he takes that one it's not going
to be checkmate you'll have the d2
square for your king
it might be unpleasant but it's it's not
gonna be made okay
so if so that's a great example you can
actually just ignore
the threat against your pawn yeah you
always want to take the knight then
yeah because your threats against his
king are going to be a million times
stronger than his threats against your
king
okay that makes sense then to know i'm
just bringing the king up because the
only move i have
very good
okay now all you have to do is find a
way to evade
the checks do is uh blocking it with the
pawns probably not a good idea right
because he just takes with the knight
but then you take his knight uh so let
me just make this full trade here
right but you're gonna be up two bishops
and that comes back to what we talked
about in the beginning
don't be afraid to trade queens when
you're attacking because
you understand that's that's fine you're
going to be up with peace
he's playing this well he he's doing the
best he can but if he takes on c3 with
the queen then yes you trade queens
okay so now
think about um so what i would do well
his this pawn is hanging right here and
uh
that's what i noticed but then i give up
the control of the c
square uh yeah you can risk it you can
take on h6
and uh you'll be able to evade the
checks there okay
but you've got to be careful he's going
to take the pawn on c3 and then you've
got to walk your king up
and zigzag your way out of this
you could have also blocked your queen
and traded
oh [ __ ] he's got this check okay you can
bring your king back
i actually missed this check be totally
frank with you
it's all good but um
[Music]
you can block with your rook
all right then he'll probably just bring
queen down
c1 and then you'll bring your king up to
e2 okay he's
surprising me very much with his
resilience i have to say king get that
get that king up
and then you can centralize it on d4 and
that king's gonna be safe if he checks
you on
on e1 oh you actually have a really sexy
move
you can block that check with oh i would
have blocked it with a bishop though
it's okay he'll repeat move so play
queen c1 you'll go come back to d2
but by blocking with the bishop you are
disallowing any checks and you're going
to lobster pincer made him
yeah i see
yeah all he can do is give you a couple
of spike checks
it's over no this guy definitely played
well
but you can see that it was a little
scary but you managed to evade the
checks
yeah all right shall we do one one more
and then a couple of notes on these two
on the on the games then we'll
maybe wrap it up that's the the the
bishop move i wouldn't even thought of
because it hangs the the rook
and i but you're threatening checkmate
yeah
it didn't even occur to me that makes a
lot of sense okay okay
that's that's good for me to know maybe
a five minute game where you
you're in a three-minute mode well you
knew five minutes i haven't done it
let's do a five minute game yeah
because the pog champs are ten plus five
so you'll have you'll definitely have
time
i can't play the fiat uh vienna against
this right he's playing the perk
uh so here do i want to just keep
developing or do i want to chase the
bishop away first
well you can also control the center
with your pawns remember that he's not
played e5 or c5
so you need to punish him for that
exactly that's actually a mainline
theory
now you can deal with this vision
guys ratings are refunded whoa thank you
anna for the raid 524 thank you so much
anna
all right so he's taken on f3 which is
kind of a mistake
i just want to push this right now don't
i bring it up to dvd yeah
grab that space grab that space
really appreciate it anna finishing up
my lesson with charlie here you guys
coming to good time bring
queen back to starting position or is
there a more active square for let's see
uh you can bring it back to the starting
position no problem and
and i want you to practice that
sometimes these are treating moves
uh they can be disconcerting to the
opponent
but because that knight on e5 you can
get it the [ __ ] out of there
yeah so do i want to do that with the
bishop or the f pawn
well do it as forcefully as possible if
you do with the bishop then he can
he doesn't have to move the pawn right
yep so just do it with the pawn then yep
go ahead
and then you can complete your
development you can move the bishop out
you can castle
this is one of the situations i'd want
to castle long considering the pawn
structure
you you well why don't you try
that's an interesting strategy i'll put
it this way it's risky
but um in the next like week or two i do
want you to try all these creative
approaches
like i give you the green light go ahead
so you got to get your pieces down uh do
i want to bring the bishop to d2 as
opposed to e
why you want to bring it out as actively
as possible
okay so bring it to e3 and stuff yeah
and also the d2 square is a pretty
decent score for the queen but you could
also bring the queen to
a more active square where it where it
protects the e4 pawn
oh i just bring it back over to f3 good
all right another question i had is when
do i want to look to open up the center
so um normally if you have a development
advantage or he has
his king in the center uh but in this
case are you
going to try to attack in the center no
you're going to be no you're going to
attack on the king side so keeping the
center relatively close is actually good
for you that way you don't have to worry
about it now that knight on h5
he's trying to put barriers to your
attack can you get that knight out of
there
yeah i can just push up this g exactly
he's probably gonna take your knight on
c3
that would be my guess
bam big reed well i i know these guys
he's going to bring his knight back and
then you have to understand
how are you going to attack his king
what needs to get opened this h file
needs to get open
and go ahead and open it again these
guys he's playing
far above his rating right now but if he
plays queen a5 here
then you know i don't know
because attacking like this is not easy
interesting now that pawn on c3 is
hanging
yeah i would get your king the hell out
of there i would evacuate it
so just get it immediately up to d2 here
yeah
and notice that the a2 pawn is hanging
but do you give a [ __ ] about this one
here's something you have to always tell
yourself when you are going for
checkmate
uh you have to always set your
priorities like when you're going for
checkmate you shouldn't worry about
pawns
um when you're in a quiet position then
it's a different story okay
so what should you do finish my plan
push this h pawn again
yeah go ahead yeah he's gonna play b4
probably
yeah so now you're trying to open the
age file okay so now he decides to take
bring i bring my queen over to the h
file now right well then he'll take
on e4 with check so that knight on f6
can you try to get it out of there first
yeah see the order of operations first
you clear the path
then you get the once you deploy the
queen
it's like i don't know why but i was
watching this airplane
video where like pilots have this thing
they say
when they can't abort or take off any
longer i think it's like v8
and it's the same thing here you want to
pave the way fully for the queen
before you actually go for the final
final okay so he's gone
knight to tribe correctly now your task
here
well okay whoops is to get that knight
out of there you need to devise
a strategy to get the knight out of
there i looked at e2
e2 for the bishop and then moving my
queen lovely
he has a pretty strong of 95 here okay
this is definitely a bit suspect so
that doesn't change what you have to do
you can't take the knight
if i take the knight with pawn what
happened he takes your queen
oh wait what oh with the rook yep the
x-ray yeah
so you got to move the queen where you
wanted to move it anyway
yeah this guy is um i'm not going to say
anything for sure but he is playing
very very well
very very well
nice oh and the nardinski jinx charlie
you are an absolute i mean this is
unbelievable
these players it's on no but it happens
even at my level i'm playing gm's and
i'll start complimenting them and the
moment i do that they
they blunder like a rooker they blonder
a queen it's like uncanny
you need to say that more often man i do
i just say it all the time that's how i
win all my games
it's just unbelievable but you know i
mean i don't want to throw any [ __ ] on
him but this guy played
fantastic game um so can i quickly
invite you to an analysis board just a
couple of concluding points on on these
two games
for sure perfect
so first game
invited
all right now after d5 uh you could have
also taken with a knight
right and kept the integrity of your
pawn structure just pointing that out
you took with the pawn
so this is all good is there any reason
to take with the knight
well to preserve your pawn structure
like taking with the pawn that pawn is
kind of weak
so if he would have played knight f6 you
would have had a hard time defending
that pawn
there's no no need to do that you could
have taken with the knight and that
that way you wouldn't have any weak
bones now he played incorrectly here
and you played perfectly bishop g5
bishop h4 is great castle's long and now
you open the g file so queen e3 does
this move makes sense
yeah so your queen position it doesn't
have to be
literally like in your opponent's face
as long as the queen is safe and a good
way to make sure the queen is safe is
that it's sheltered behind
his own pawns rook g1 g5 now here
let's say that you wanted to defend the
spawn on b2
how could you have done that bring up
the c pawn
very good and that's probably would have
been even more prudent i
to be honest with you i myself
underestimated or
sorry i can't talk underestimated his
chances
but um as soon as queen takes h6 is
played
you have to have a light bulb that goes
on in your head and you basically
just tell yourself okay i have only one
goal
which is to escape the checks and i will
sacrifice anything
that needs to be sacrificed uh in order
to do that and that's the way that you
find a move like bishop e2
because you are constantly telling
yourself that if he makes a move that's
not a check then he gets checkmated
and uh by the way here could you find
the most accurate move
you played f takes e3 yeah just taking
the knight
or even moving the king up to d3 yeah
very good and finally
game all right
i'll invite you to another board
all right
okay so yeah this guy was strung now the
move d4 that makes sense right he hasn't
played
these moves so you kind of punish him by
controlling the center
d5 queen back f4 so if you if you would
have played bishop f4 then
he would have had the option of
remaining on e5 with the knight you
could have taken
and ruined his pawn structure but here
you ensure that the knight has to move
back
okay g4 is good
um so here you could have also taken his
knight in order to keep your pawn
structure intact
that would have just been an option
pointing that out
and uh if you wanted to reduce the
influence of this bishop what would you
have done here
the same move that you could have made
in the previous yeah i would have just
pushed up the c
pawn right blunting the bishop
okay so h4 king d2 evacuating the king
yeah so everything here very logical and
in certain situations
uh you should also consider sacrificing
on h5 not necessarily here but in
certain situations
even here because what you do is you
clear out
the h file and now what are you going to
do on your next move let's say that
black plays something random
what would be the fastest way of getting
the rook to h1 i'd bring up the bishop
so i'd bring it
excellent how do you bring it up with
tempo
uh i mean that knight's hanging but that
also blocks my rook so
okay but but here's the thing um
i want to make after you play bishop h3
uh that bishop can and that you make a
good point about the h fell but let's
say the knight moves
where can this bishop go uh f4
or f5 sorry or even
what other square ah deliver a check all
the way to e6 i see
and they can drive the king into the
corner and now
and now i bring the rook over and now
you bring the rook over he's got a
couple of checks here
but uh you can sidestep the checks you
can go up
and then you could zigzag back down and
then even you could go king d2 right
into the teeth and he's got no checks
so or i guess king f3 is more accurate
to defend the pawn
and you win the game with a checkmate so
these sacrifices you have to consider
when you have this priority
of getting a rook to h1 uh that's when
you have to get allow yourself the
opportunity to sack but i liked the move
bishop e2
and uh okay of course he made it a bit
easier for you but knight c4 check would
have been the unpleasant move this would
have
well what's the problem with taking like
what what happens now
no i can't take that knight right so
this gets very messy i mean maybe you
can move the king he takes your bishop
this
this is anybody's game but
nonetheless i think you played you
played very well you demonstrated all
the key attacking ideas
so i would say in the next couple of
days um
maybe and not my business to tell you
what to do but i would put the emphasis
on five minute games
just to give yourself an opportunity to
practice the openings and practice we
talked about a lot of concepts today
through the problems
um and i really want you to be able to
cement them so you can play a mix of
three and five
but pogchamps is gonna be ten plus five
so even by playing five minute
you're already challenging yourself okay
that sounds good to me
and uh you know grind the problems as
well the puzzles you're in
fantastic tactical form i'm really happy
with with the progress
next time we'll work more intensely on
on on white openings
and i'll prepare drills based on the
exercises that you struggled with
with today and we'll keep on hammering
at the uh
various concepts all right that sounds
great to me man
thank you fantastic charlie my pleasure
uh
i think we're making great progress then
despite all that i've said today i'm i'm
pretty happy
so thanks again for for getting up so
early it's always
always a pleasure man yeah of course man
anytime just hit me up whenever you're
free
fantastic all right we'll talk to you
soon looking forward to the next session
charlie have a great
rest of the stream you too man have a
great day thank you
bye
[Music]
you